what's up guys welcome to the shop show
hot takes us a very special hot take
because my boy Marvin vittori the number
three middleweight badass on the planet
is breaking down this week's UFC 276 Big
Time middleweight fights you're talking
about the main event Izzy Cannon air
he's breaking down Sean Strickland knows
very well versus Alex Pierre he's gonna
give you some hot takes and this episode
of hot takes is brought to you by rain
body fuel rain body fuel there's nothing
like it let's get into it Mr Marvin
vittori Italy's Finest what's up brother
you might be the best dressed dude that
we've definitely had on uh in studio I
think especially fight wise I think
that's right fellas right I have to
represent you really do there I you know
I was expecting a nice outfit but you
did not disappoint my man now you are
the perfect guy to give us this shop
show hot take because this Saturday is
UFC 276. there's some middleweights
fighting there's some middleweights
fighting and you have a few things you
know in common with those guys uh the
first fight I'd like you to talk about
and I'll do my best to navigate through
it would be oxpiera and uh Sean
Strickland and for those that don't know
and correct me if I'm wrong you you
trained a little bit with Strickland
correct I train a lot of Strickland yeah
a lot a lot and how do you see this
fight going down
so he moved to Vegas right and in all
honesty
I think it was the best move from him
for him but he's a beast man don't get
me wrong like everything every time we
train like actually train just a little
bit uh in Vegas not too long ago and uh
he's always game he's always a beast
don't get me wrong he's a dog right
he's a daughter he has a system like
he's really like defensive responsible
too that's why like
like he pushes the pace and he goes
forward that much he's not he's not
stupid he wants to play that like that
Antics where he's stupid and he just
goes forward but there's always
something behind these people and I'm
I'm one of one of those myself but you
do any type of way where Alex Pierre who
you know I don't think he's ranked or
might be ranked 15 he's jumping all the
way to fight Strickland because to me
it's pretty clear what the UFC is trying
to do right they're like Pierre we just
need to win this one then the story
against you and Izzy you'll get the next
title shot I'm like he's just gonna
catapult to the jump to the queue like
that you know if he wins against
Strickland which I don't think he will
even though I mean uh even what I was
just saying but he's an underdog or I'm
sorry Strickland is an underdog
Strickland is an underdog but I know
Strickland like it's yeah it's it's not
it's not that easy because like he
doesn't wrestle but if he wants to
wrestle he has some wrestling too so I
don't look at Strickland especially when
I just fights like his his fight IQ is
high you know like he wants to play that
you know the dumb role but he's not dumb
he's not dumb you can tell when he
fights so I would assume no one Alex
Pierre is you know world-class Striker
Strickland you know famous himself with
Striker too but he's not Alex per year
you know type Striker but so I think
he's gonna be able to mix it up
Strickland has been like strict on one
thing of strict on his supportings
everything like he spars like basically
every day like hard right hard but like
like I said defensively he's very good
so that's why you can get away with
sparring so much so that makes sense so
but not all the time horror sometimes
you put on small glove and then he can
turn into horror but
um but he's not like Reckless
because that's a narrative on him like
he like he's really
I mean uh he'll if you let him bully you
like you'll be I've seen sometimes in
bullying people like you know like but
at the same time like no himself is not
Reckless yeah like I would pay to watch
you and him I would pay because I heard
you go hard too that's the rumor yeah
you go pretty hard too yeah I mean
sometimes you go to Vegas and I like
these guys they Spar hard even with
small gloves and I'm fine with it but to
me is a little bit weird yeah that's
wild
um
but most of the time if I put on small
gloves then it's more like hard on the
grappling yeah
like you'll make it real but it's not
like you're not really trying to crack
no like yeah of course not but
um so it can build up to that times but
it's not like normal but you think uh
you think Sean Strickland gets it done
against Pierre I think so because he's
able to mix it up he has a little more
experience and
um
and again like uh
not to like I mean prayer is not gonna
watch this but I think uh um
Ephesians box
definitely like if it's just if you'll
be like about punching Strickland it'll
be hard but if you'll kick a lot then
could get dicey right yeah but then
again like you'll open himself or take
this I don't know but I
overall a big Strickland but it's not
gonna be like a walk in the park yeah I
think if yeah it's very reachy too yeah
I think if PIRA you know doesn't get
done early Strickland's gonna be the
decision I agree with you on that and
then in the the main event which I'm
sure you'll be paying close attention to
you got Izzy versus Deer Cannon air now
Izzy's the biggest favorite on the card
you know obviously all the MMA experts
out there and all the analysts are going
to say you know this is a easy fight for
for Izzy you see it as an easy fight uh
so they asked me earlier and I'm like oh
yeah he's just gonna do it like I wasn't
really I wasn't really thinking through
too much and I still think it's gonna do
it but it's not gonna be that easy I
mean to be to be honest man I think like
um
easy is not getting any better to be
honest even though like people are
saying oh yeah it's getting better by
the day like I don't think so at the
same time canonie it is a little bit
basic like he doesn't really like
I mean like he'll he'll he'll crack hard
he'll kick hard he's like a heavyweight
yeah but it's the speed yeah he's
powerful yeah it's the speed uh it's
just easy just it's almost like he puts
up this like smoke walls where like it's
all it's all small but you got to see
through and yeah you need to be really
experienced to see through those walls
like for like that's that's one of the
mistakes I did in my in my last fight
with him where I gave him like a little
even too much respect
um on some of the areas
um so I think
like like especially like I mean I don't
feel like
um
uh Canada is going to be able to like
walk him down and like really like like
land power shots on him and so then uh
it's not gonna be easy because you'll
have to like figure them out because
like like I said he brings like uh Power
so you have to yeah you have to respect
that
but um I think you'll be you'll be able
to to find a way so you think as he gets
it done later third or fourth I don't
think I don't think it's as easy people
think I don't think he's gonna finish
him to be honest oh you don't oh wow
well yeah I mean the knock on is the not
on you know I would never knock you out
for this but people were like oh and
title fights you know he he'll get ahead
and then Coast a little bit to me it's
like he's fighting really [ __ ] good
guys like these guys are hard to finish
I really realized how easy fights right
like because of course I've been
studying him and like and especially
even I fought him twice so one Split
Decision yeah but yeah yeah
um
yeah
just because uh we'll get crazy back
there like well yeah we'll get yeah
we'll get to the food truck so
you'll get into a fight and then uh
he'll look for that like when I fought
him right away right he'll uh he'll he's
facing me and he he like threw like a
jab and he see like I'm reacting the
right way then he threw then he threw a
cross and he sees them reacting the
right way then he throw like an inside
Loki and he sees her like I react the
right way then he throws like um he's
still Orthodox and I'm suppo and he
threw like a outside leg kick and I just
like put weight on my leg but I don't
really like block it block it and he's
like ah maybe maybe that's maybe that's
a hole you know yeah he's looking for
the hell [ __ ] fight Southpaw just to
he falls up with my the whole [ __ ]
fight
so that's how he fights and and um and
then he realized he can't hurt me anyway
yeah because I'm like I'm taking it and
I'm like I didn't really check it but
like I checked a few but not many I
think I took like 50 plus [ __ ] Jesus
Christ yeah but but they didn't really
bother me like after yeah of course it
wasn't like you know it wasn't pleasant
but but yeah but I was like putting
weight on it and they were sliding up
like there was just few that were like
kind of like really like relevant yeah I
I think going back to Canada I think
with Izzy you know with his region it's
gonna be tough he's gonna be looking for
the whole if it doesn't find a hole or
if it doesn't find the hole that's gonna
be like uh really like relevant to like
create like a substantial how like like
damage damage yeah like like it did with
Costa where like you start like
compensating with others and then you're
like I don't know then you can kind of
you can go upstairs yeah then he'll just
Cruise like like with Romero like her
Cruise or what uh if if like uh like a
uh Paulo Costa or you know even with
Whitaker then if they if the guy feels
almost pressure like I gotta get
something going here and they rush in
that's when he lights you up that's when
he gets the finishes so I agree I think
as he gets done I think it's as easy as
everybody thinks you know he said it's
gonna be like Anderson Silva versus uh
Force Griffin you know no hell no I I
don't think he should be that easy but I
do think as he gets it it's uh it's um
like they're off by a mile whoever like
Compares Anderson Silva to
why because like I said like
he's not he's a smart fighter he's an
experienced fighter like he can he's
really really good at dealing with like
lights pressure all this [ __ ] like is he
like was like he's like walking into the
park when he's going to fight but he's
not courageous he's not he doesn't take
risks in the fight [ __ ] Anderson
Silva was going in there trying to like
demolish people sometimes unless you're
a Brazilian
like some of those fights against other
Brazilians he got you know you get [ __ ]
for because he was born but again it was
a lot of times with the other it was the
Anderson's Falls the other guy's fault
let's take a little break from Marvin
vittori breaking down some of the
biggest middleweight fights in this
weekend's big pay-per-view card UFC 276.
because this is brought to you by the
best Kratom on the planet the only
creative I trust the kratom's the wild
west out there but not with my friends
at happy hippo if you want to try Kratom
but safe Kratom trade them that your boy
uses on stage when I'm doing stand-up
during podcast the 7000 podcasts I do a
week or just working out I use this
Kratom happyhippo herbals.com use promo
code sick boy you get 20 off for life
again that's Happy Hippo
herbals.com all right and promo code
Stick Boy 20 off for life you're welcome
now let's get back to this
heartache for you you know your fight
got pushed you're you're fighting uh in
Paris in September now which I think is
a blessing for you because you're going
to have your your fan base out there
going crazy for you uh when you look at
Robert Whittaker obviously you know
Staple in the middleweight division uh
you know former world champion is there
things you look at there and you feel
like you have the advantage over
Whitaker I have a lot of advantages one
of the things that excites me I don't
know why but I mean it is cool I'm gonna
I'm gonna be breaking into pound for
pound uh because I think he's ranked
like number 11 pound per pound so if you
beat him yeah
100
so that's one of the things that excites
me about then obviously it's my first
time in Europe since uh I got signing
with the UFC
and um but yeah stylistically man like
he's a karate guy like he's really like
it's really bouncy and I think the three
rounds actually favors him a little bit
but just uh just about me to make
another adjustment really I would like
five rounds I wish it was five I asked
for it too yeah that should be a five
rounds five hundred percent at your guys
level yeah especially where you rank
this should be a five round five I think
so yeah should be a five round fight um
and then uh we'll get more into that
food truck but then the the last fight I
want to get your take on is Paolo Costa
and Luke rockhold are fighting how do
you see that going down I don't see it
well for Luke Rocco to be honest I think
Luke rockhold is thinking to like uh
to take down to uh take Costa down you
know but um I don't think he's able to
do that easier said than done yeah
easier said than done I think
and if they stay standing like
[ __ ] I know I talked [ __ ]
before but like uh Eco power for sure
yeah Apollo has some power yeah yeah
yeah yeah I think with Luke his thing it
you know too he you know he took a
three-year layoff and then him fight
yawn into disaster but
is ever going to be able to make 185
again he's a big dude he's [ __ ] huge
do you get down with his uh kind of [ __ ]
talking all that like do you see Global
Tech Sarah he's like you got to decide
if you want to be world champion or you
want to be like uh Instagram you know
only fans girl like you got to decide
which lady he's Twitter it's amazing to
be honest yeah you like it yeah
he's a wild boy yeah he's a weirdo like
he's like um he's like he's one of the
few guys that even after I fought him
because you know I want to use when they
give you like a like like a guy that you
have to fight like you start studying
him and like you kind of like
like try to like study him and study him
also mentally yes this guy's a [ __ ]
weirdo I couldn't make anything out of
whatever that he was saying or he's a
little crazy he's so crazy see all over
the place yeah he's a little crazy yeah
I get a little worried about him with
his social media Antics and I I do think
if Luke rockhold has his if he's in the
race right state of mind and he's ready
to go and he's committed to it skill
wise I think Luke can beat him
the sports evolved so much man yeah now
I see what you're saying I've seen I I
was seeing him like um so I was a
Churchill right because uh I trained
boxing with Julian Chua and he used to
be a Churchill before so I used to go
Churchill and uh he showed up right
after my training and he started
training this is Luca okay and he was he
was talking some [ __ ] on YouTube and I
said let's Spar and he said oh like
basically like because I told him like
oh you said uh you know you said that I
was a sexy fight for you like yeah yeah
you guys were talking [ __ ] yeah I said
that's my middleweights dude you guys
are out of your mind so let's Spar and
he's like oh no now I'm just coming back
I'm like all right whatever but then I
saw him training a little bit I don't I
don't know maybe I mean you know I've
heard Courtney is saying a couple times
out like like he's a different dude when
he really goes into camp and prepares
for a fight yeah I heard that you know
I've seen guys that sometimes really
like change when like they're in a fight
Camp 100 their game time guys but but
first you know like you cannot teach
yourself new [ __ ] around the moment bro
like stuff yeah yeah it's not like so
you think Paulo gets it done I think so
man vicious too much too much yeah I
mean I think so well there's some
freaking takes from a guy who knows a
thing or two about all the fighters I
just mentioned we can have a better guy
in the house to break down the
middleweight division this is Marvin
vittori this is hot takes thanks brother
let's go